[Music]
in Mythbusters news tonight I show a bit
of my ding-dong-ditch haha that was one
of my favorite games growing up she was
looking out when you put it like I
didn't know that's [ __ ] up I thought
it was so funny to like ring someone's
doorbell and [ __ ] run and you're like
hiding and you watch them open the door
and they're like what the [ __ ] and then
they just blow the door but I thought I
was like looking pranking reading or
just more you keep sharing with Buster
look you know how notoriously when I
first learned that I have so much fun
playing that with my friends after they
went home I did it alone you supposed to
be like a like a shared with your
fencing ready went to the same house
over and over again I don't I don't want
this y'all may realize they're not going
to open a door no more
well that's I'm playing spin the bottle
of your smells dude
[Laughter]
the radio show Infowars has claimed that
nasa runs a child slave colony on Mars
whoa what that's pretty cool that's
crazy
I mean it's info well not the child
slave colony part with the fact that we
have the capability to even do that's
pretty awesome if that's true so they're
there busting the myth ah no so NASA
unhandsome it I guess
NASA actually had to respond to this
[ __ ] so let me go back a little bit
you guys know Infowars that's alex jones
channel they uh they're super fun who's
Alex Alex Jones is 91 Trump's best
friend and like during the election you
helped them out a lot
you got best friend but then life he's
like a goose / in-between libertarian
and conspiracy life and
he's got the very interesting channel on
the YouTube nah yeah I think it's on
YouTube but I like it he's also it's a
radio show Oh what he does upload his
show to YouTube as well I like his voice
very sick mm-hmm what do you talk about
crazy [ __ ] off the time yeah 100 NASA
respond to this [ __ ] cuz I want say holy
shut their sorry asses down before I get
there so I'm gonna I'm gonna tell you
guys you like the son of mine was
annoyed I just I didn't want to know why
go ahead go ahead no I want to hear your
voice okay so so anyway so this Infowars
show it airs on 118 radio stations
nationwide specially Wow so taking muses
on a whole bunch of computers nationwide
yeah so on this show he started talking
about pedophilia and how the Vatican had
another scandal with pedos so he had
this guest named Robert David Steele was
an American activist and former CIA case
officer
so he's known for promotes the promotion
of open-source intelligence but it seems
like he's also into conspiracy theories
because he's the one that proposed that
NASA is sending kids on a 20-year
mission to Mars to become sexily but
then they're going to be adults but they
agent lower so I'm going to show you
guys the clip of that interview where
Robert is talking to Alex Alex just got
some crazy like inside penis it's with
the type of guests that he has though
it's just mind-blowing he has it's one
special with that with a Louis Farrakhan
oh [ __ ] yeah it was pretty crazy I was
like the hell this is intense
did that play but I liked his well let
me just point out that pedophilia does
not stop with sodomizing children it
goes straight into terrorizing them to
Adrenaline's their blood and then murder
during them it also includes murdering
them so that they can have their bone
marrow harvested as well as body parts
you know philia is much as the original
growth hormone yes yes it's an
anti-aging thing and this may strike
your listeners is way out but we
actually believe that there is a colony
on Mars that is populated by children
who were kidnapped and sent into space
on a 20-year ride so that once they get
to Mars they have no alternative but to
be slaves on the Mars colony ours all
kinds of thought look I know at 90% of
the NASA missions are secret novel told
by high-level NASA engineers that you
have no idea there's so much someone on
but then it goes off and all that
through I mean it jumps on but I know
this we see a bunch of mechanical
wreckage on Mars and people who are like
that you know mechanic getting all your
conspirators clearly they don't want us
looking into what's happening does every
time probe is going where they turn them
off Alex you're one of the most original
guys on the air and I was you ask what
should you do I think he should be the
truth channel in America I think I like
his voice because he sounds like a
classic car to me yes he does with us
but not like a hot rod but more like a
like a smaller one you know like I
thought he was imitating a [ __ ] car
across Virginia and you know when I was
a look at the gold cart yeah I like them
yet the most interesting characters on
his show and sometimes you're just like
maybe it's real because he has like hi
former like officials that were military
this guy CIA like they're intelligent
people they're not [ __ ] dump box how
do we know he's really CIA who because
every time I see this stuff they don't
show me the credentials I need to see
the credentials because some of the guys
that he gets on the show like they're
also promoting like a book or all these
things and in that there's the
credentials and stuff
sort of NASA ought to say oh [ __ ] you
got to say NASA what is necessary for
national astronautical are an optical
phase dynamical actions astronomical
I've never heard astronautical yeah but
that's not like a compliment do you're
[ __ ] doing some astronomical things
bro yeah so NASA's spokesperson for the
Mars exploration said quote there are no
humans on Mars there are active Rovers
on Mars there was a rumor going around
that we thought there weren't there are
there are no human sure almost get there
like I didn't even get there with SpaceX
why how would they get there yeah um I
don't want to say some crazy [ __ ] though
I thought they were gonna say like we're
not even active we're sending kids out
there so Martians can have something of
fun oh [ __ ] alright I thought they were
going to say we're sending kids out
there for something more valuable other
than just to [ __ ] above them but like so
that we can start our colony in like a
new world out there you expect the NASA
to do that
no this the guy that was man what was he
talking about like scaring them to get
like bone marrow because it's like the
Fountain of Youth
pretty much like that's what he's
claiming that they're killing these kids
or their bone marrow orbit that's all
you got to do I think I think you got a
cult like when you kill them I think or
when you make them like really excited
or something and you kill them and
that's when you extract the bone marrow
my let changes the flavor story if they
were saying well not everything
oh that's what they said that's what
they Sharia is this story my energy for
the video no so when you're saying it to
sound like you had heard it somewhere
else I was like wait what where did I
wrong they mean I read wrong what they
were saying in the video or Colonel
Sanders over those hands dude yeah so
this entire interview of the whole video
is just them
going off on some I can praise your [ __ ]
and you watch this sometimes it's very
interesting for entertainment purposes
of course I don't believe in it but I
think the conspiracy theory world is
really fun because there's like some
truth or no truth you just don't know
you got to be the detective yourself and
believe what you want to believe I can't
even get my regular life together I try
to think about theories right now but
it's like it's like it's like this it's
like so you like watching TV shows you
like watching things that are kind of Oh
what if right so things like making a
murder you like watch it and you go it's
kind of a conspiracy theory right
because it's like well that whole town
they might be in on it the police might
be in on that they might be setting that
guy up I don't know I don't think I get
like that because it's not coming I
guess I can't get that invested and lost
like that because for me I'm always
thinking like I need to do my own
investigation because this is biased
[ __ ] coming from Dick Tracy here it does
do that I think that's how people like
they get invested because they watch
that and they go I own my own
investigation and then you go on
Wikipedia let me say some that's this
guy right here yep
for me yeah and you do that all the time
and we're watching something you already
like looking up a whole bunch of [ __ ]
I like okay yeah yeah it's not a bad
thing I'm just saying that's what you're
getting Barlow fences yeah it's good to
double verify your information though
because if you just hear from one source
people just take it as true that's kind
of like how people nowadays they see a
[ __ ] Facebook video and whatever they
see in whatever type of propaganda you
guys think it's a [ __ ] fact when you
haven't even checked the [ __ ] source
yeah which is so stupid to me I know
some money like that that's related to
me that does that all the time and this
[ __ ] just repost Facebook videos
all the time that kind of affiliates to
his own agenda it's so stupid it's like
bro
did you fact check that [ __ ] no you go
no this is true look what they said [ __ ]
dude
I go by one rule does it bother me
like really bother me if not who cares I
hope you guys enjoy this video for more
please subscribe to our Channel and you
can check out the last video right here
[Music]
you
[Music]